disappointing night for the Labour
leader and there will be causing a huge
thank you to the returning officer and
all the staff and the police that have
ensured a fair and democratic election
has taken place today and also to
congratulate and thank my fellow
candidates for their participation in
this election and also a very heartfelt
thanks to the people of Islington Norse
for electing me again for the tenth time
to represent easing to North in
Parliament I'm very very proud to do so
and I've learned so much from the people
are visiting to North and it's my pride
in my pleasure to continue to be their
representative in Parliament I also want
to thank Ruth Hayes our agent for this
election and all of the wonderful
friends comrades and supporters in
Essington North Labor Party for the huge
effort they put in in this election
campaign and they put in all the time
to carry a message of hope and justice
all over our constituency and through me
I hope to a wider world the pressure on
those surrounding politicians is often
very very high indeed the media
intrusion on people's lives is very high
indeed and the attacks that take place
against family and loved ones of
politicians continue and they're
disgraceful and frankly they are
disgusting I want to take this
opportunity to thank my family my close
friends and those that have been close
by and been very supportive during this
and every other election campaign I want
to thank my three sons for the huge
support they give me and thank my wife
Lara Alvarez for all that she puts up
with because of the way in which the
media behaved towards me towards her and
indeed
my party during this election campaign
and this
this is obviously a very disappointing
night for the Labour Party with the
result that we've got but I want to say
this in the election campaign we put
forward a manifesto of hope a manifesto
of unity and a manifesto that would help
to right the wrongs and the in justices
and inequalities that exist in this
country for those who need housing those
who need an effective health service
that will deliver for them and those
children that need a school that is
properly funded and they're not being
told by oversized classes and a
manifesto that gave hope in dealing with
the environmental crisis that world
faces by investing for the future
through a green Industrial Revolution
all of those policies were extremely
popular during the election campaign and
remain policies that have huge popular
support all across this country
however brexit has so polarized and
divided debate in this country it has
overridden so much of a normal political
debate and I recognize that has
contributed to the results that the
Labour Party has received this evening
all across this country the issues of
social justice and the issues of needs
of people will not go away just because
brexit is dealt with in the way in which
Boris Johnson presumably plans to deal
with it at the moment all those issues
will come back center stage in the
debate and the fundamental labour
message about justice and equality
within our society is going to be one
that is there for all time because it's
the very core of what my party believes
him and what I will always advocate on
behalf of my constituency and on behalf
of my party I want to also make it clear
that I will not lead the party in any
future general
and campaign I will discuss with our
party to ensure there is a process now
of reflection on this result and on the
policies that the party will take going
forward and I will lead the party during
that period to ensure that discussion
takes place and we move on into the
future
because I'm in they're very going to go
from the